Robert Downey jr. teases returning as
Iron Man to MCU one day and in other
news
Greg refuses to cut his own hair I love
to see that social distancing is
communism
I hope this video is just Robert Downey
jr. saying maybe this is from the cosmic
wonder let's get to it
how's it going everybody gets warned
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about Marvel and
all things relating to the MCU now for
the past few months there's been a lot
of talk about Robert Downey jr. possibly
coming back to the Marvel Cinematic
Universe of course fans are super
excited about it but despite many
different reports from many different
media sources it is not yet confirmed
however last night it seems like we may
have gotten a little bit of a hint from
Robert Downey jr. himself that
eventually he could make his way back to
the Marvel Cinematic Universe Robert
Downey jr. prominence along with
something that Joe Russo said last night
in a live stream he did on Instagram
lead us to believe that we may actually
know-how and win Iron Man could return
to the MCU and I'll break down
everything you need to know in this
video if you're new be sure to subscribe
to stay up to date on all things
relating to the MCU and next week I'll
be starting weekly giveaways so to start
off about a month ago there was a
station came out about Robert Downey jr.
possibly returning to the MCU under two
conditions a lot of various media
outlets were reading this news and if
you didn't hear about it I'll briefly
explain please the first condition was
of course five pictures you can get Iron
Man back for the right price however a
recent rumors suggest that Robert Downey
jr. is willing to accept way less than
his normal pay and this makes sense if
you consider the fact that it's been
revealed that Robert Downey jr. made 75
million dollars for Avengers and game
alone and that is according to Forbes so
he's not exactly hurting for money but
the second condition is that he beaten a
still has residual and this makes
perfect sense Robert Downey jr. and Tom
Holland got very close to one another
while filming the first spider-man
homecoming movie and of course the
Avengers films as well and recently they
were both in doolittle together so
according to some reports of
a month ago these were the two
conditions for Robert Downey jr.
returned to the MCU now last night the
Russo brothers did a live stream and
they were talking about Avengers endgame
and if they could come back
many fans want the Russo brothers to
come back and direct more Marvel movies
but the Risser brothers have said that
they're taking a break for a while
however live stream Joe Russo said we do
have a lot of fun working on MCU films
together maybe we'll have to do it again
someday and after that comment
Robert Downey Robert Downey jr. to
return and of course the Russo brothers
not to mention all of the reports
recently that State Robert Downey jr.
has been talking with Marvel Studios and
there is a connection between the
resoures return and Robert Downey jr.
--zz return the Russo brothers have
stated a few times now that they would
come back to direct a Avengers Secret
Wars film now Secret Wars is essentially
a bunch of different versions of a bunch
of different heroes from different
universes colliding and I've said it
before and I'll say it again this would
be the perfect opportunity for Robert
Downey jr. to return it would be very
brief and it wouldn't eliminate his
death because the Tony Stark that we
would be seen would be from addictive
universe everything seems to point
towards Avengers secret Wars about a
world being the next Avengers in game
type of event especially since one
division series coming to Disney Plus
and a Doctor Strange and the multiverse
of madness are going to be over the
multiverse and shows like Loki are going
to explore alternate timelines as well
and not to mention we can assume Tom
Hollands spider-man is going to be in
the next big Avengers film as well so
that would mean his conditions would be
met and Iron Man could return now
unfortunately this movie would not
happen for several several years in fact
what most likely won't happen until
probably about ten years from now that
is a good thing right now Marvel needs
to move past Iron Man he died and is
in-game and we're moving on to a new
phase yes missing but we have to move on
and we have to build you've seen all the
right things this winter's team and
x-men team and the Fantastic Four have
to come into play as we're seeing
they have all of their big films
separately they all come together in one
huge crossover event like infinity war
and endgame so the Infinity Saga took
ten years to build up to infinity war
and endgame so this next saga will most
likely take ten years as well so if
Robert Downey jr. does eventually return
it seems like we're going to have to
wait quite a while but we could see him
and it sounds like he is definitely
talking with Marvel Studios about it
but let me know what you think let me
know what you think about what the
wrister brothers said and what Robert
Downey's juniors response was and would
you like to see him return let me know
your thoughts in the comments down below
and don't forget to subscribe with
notifications turned on so you can stay
up to date on everything relating to the
MCU for live updates you can follow me
on Twitter and as always thank you all
so much for watching
I want him back right now this next
movie Iron Man vs. danos both back
immediately I mean looking at this quote
here from RDJ the people will move us
towards what they want that's more of a
elaboration on the concept of being open
of course the people want him to return
I mean there's people who are like
ourselves who are out there saying like
it's too soon the death would be
rendered a little bit meaningless or
undercut I don't know about meaningless
but definitely undercut if he returned
back I mean I listen to the whole
hour-long podcast he did with Joe Rogan
and he talked quite extensively about
how he doesn't think it would be a good
idea that it could weaken the impact of
endgame and the whole character journey
and the whole the purpose of it that
being said I mean the concept of him
returning for like a cameo in Secret
Wars or some film down the road I'm not
opposed to I think it has to get to the
point though where we believe he's
probably not gonna come back like
there's nothing it has to get to the
point where they've sold us on it's not
gonna happen there's been so long
there's no way where it really is a
genuine surprise so even the idea of him
returning in Secret Wars by this point
because of the early speculation that
all right he's like that saloon oh now I
won't be surprised it really has to be
like many years and then suddenly like
oh my god he's
I don't know about this whole it has to
be wood Tom Holland thing I mean I know
they're buddies and all that I don't
know why it has to be like no only wood
Tom Holland Mel Gibson formed his
relationship with Downey now Danny's
forming his route Tom Hallman that way
he can pull Tom Holland out of a funk
with Tom Holly he's the young calm
haunts lost time just but always life
away he's got many many more years to
really screw himself over and the public
I got some maturing to do and then when
he faults Robert Downey jr. will be
there to save him and pay for his
insurance on a set and I think that's
what our DJ is really hoping for to
mentor him down the road he wants to be
his real-life Iron Man
outside of the MCU hence Doolittle wanna
--then I'm with you in that sense that I
don't want to see him anytime soon
beyond you know what will be the
requisite bummers that he's gone little
alludes whatnot
and I also agree with you I think they
have to do this in a way where it would
be an ultimate surprise I don't know
about the Tom Holland bit because that
suggests to me like maybe they're
talking about this in the sense that he
would come back and be an actual
character and not just like a cameo
spider-man is also in a hotbed of
multi-universe activity I can see it
working but yeah I just don't want it to
happen anytime soon I do believe though
that yeah what the people want will move
us toward it you know that's about the
most hopeful thing I got of that that's
about the most hopeful thing I got out
of this that's about the most hopeful
thing I got out of this because you know
he's again know I think I'll do good
three more time yeah I don't know that's
the most optimistic I can be like of
course he's willing to put on the suit
again for the right price and now I just
hope that he sticks to his guns and the
same with the Russo brothers I'm kind of
like them all to get some nice distance
from this also so that we can latch on
to some other characters I mean this is
a scary time for Marvel because even
though they do still have a good amount
of people continuing through two of
their biggest flagship heroes are gone
so you know I think we need to give
whoever the next generation of the
phases are gonna be their time to really
grab our hearts and then bring us Robert
Downey jr.
it's a scary time for Marvel feel like
everyone's really excited for what they
got in store I mean yeah there are
presents at Comic Con and just the sole
fact that they have x-men and Fantastic
Four now in development I feel like
that's gonna be plenty to get people not
really thinking about Iron Man yes sure
I don't mean iron
scary's not the right choice of words
here John it's not they are not in a
scary time it just makes me apprehensive
on their behalf that they have to
introduce a bunch of new stuff now that
they have said goodbye finally in a
finite way it's just some of their
biggest characters yeah I don't know
about the Russos returning for another
Avengers movie I like the idea that like
Joss Whedon had the first two the Russos
had next two I think it would be cool if
you handed off the reins to whoever it
comes next I could wait et yeah the
number one name for any new Marvel
property I like that they named the
secret ORS as if like the Russos
specialty is just let's do the biggest
tips in the universe together I think
it'd be cool to Russo's went back to a
smaller MCU film and a smaller MCU it's
like a hundred million dollars less as
opposed to 2 under million they kicked
it off with Winter Soldier and it would
be cool if they went back to something a
little bit more grounded
I'd say the verb for both of them it's
it when you make such a staple in the
MCU it's hard to break away from that
image and branch out I think it's like
that for the superhero medium generally
speaking but these guys are
exceptionally talented but as this new
stands yeah that I'd say this warranted
a video warrant I subscribe to cosmic
wonder if you haven't done so already do
you want Robert Downey jr. to return to
Iron Man sooner than later
how long of a distance would you want to
between do you not want him to return at
all do you think Iron Man was overrated
Iron Man two underappreciated subscriber
the real rejects click that notification
bell and last but not least I wanted to
shout out some patrons really fast we
have a reward here where I get axed or
delete takes BTS our exclusive lens
stories as well and also we do name
call-outs for these guys just a small
handful left let's do it right now
Marcus word Amon Bailey are like
Cayla waters melanie Faber burns reviews
Justin Martin love you guys thank you
guys for your support thank you guys
behind the scenes thank you guys guys
are the best thank you EFT thank you
just you and girls especially Mellon
ladies thank you how you do